- [Instructor] Let's look at a reaction
between a weak acid, acetic acid,
and a strong base, sodium hydroxide.
Let's say we have 100 milliliters
of a 2.0 molar solution
of aqueous acetic acid,
and that's mixed with 100 milliliters
of a 1.0 molar solution of
aqueous sodium hydroxide.
Our goal is to find the pH
of the resulting solution
at 25 degrees Celsius.
When the weak acid reacts
with the strong base,
a neutralization reaction occurs.
So our first step is to figure out
how many moles of our
weak acid are present
and also how many moles of
our strong base are present.
Let's start with the weak acid.
We're gonna use the molarity equation.
Molarity is equal to moles over liters.
So for our weak acid, the
concentration is 2.0 molar,
so we plug that in,
and the volume is 100 milliliters
which is equal to 0.100 liters.
Solving for x,
we find that there are
0.20 moles of acetic acid.
For our strong base, the
concentration is 1.0 molar,
and the volume is 100 milliliters
which is 0.100 liters.
So solving for x, x is
equal to 0.10 moles of NaOH.
And because NaOH is a strong
base, it dissociates 100%.
So if there's 0.10 moles of NaOH,
there's also 0.10 moles
of hydroxide ions, OH-.
In solution,
the hydroxide anions will
react with acetic acid.
So our next step is to look
at the net ionic equation
for this weak acid-strong base reaction.
In the net ionic equation,
acetic acid reacts with hydroxide anions
to form the acetate anion and water.
Because this neutralization
reaction goes to completion,
we draw an arrow going to the right
instead of an equilibrium arrow.
And instead of an ICE table
where the E stands for equilibrium,
we use an ICF table,
where I is the initial amount of moles,
C is the change in moles,
and F is the final amount of moles.
We've already calculated
the initial amount of moles
of acetic acid to be 0.20,
and the initial amount of moles
of hydroxide anions to be 0.10.
If we assume the reaction
hasn't happened yet,
the initial amount of moles
of acetate would be zero.
Next, we look at the coefficients
in our balanced net ionic equation.
The mole ratio of hydroxide
anions to acetic acid
is one-to-one.
Therefore, if we have 0.10
moles of hydroxide anions,
that's gonna react with
0.10 moles of acetic acid.
So for the change,
we can write minus 0.10
under hydroxide anions,
and also minus 0.10 under acetic acid.
For the acetate anion,
there's a coefficient of one
in the balanced net ionic equation.
Therefore, if we're losing 0.10
moles for our two reactants,
we're going to gain 0.10
moles of the acetate anion.
So when the reaction comes to
completion for acetic acid,
we started with 0.20
moles and we lost 0.10,
so we're gonna have 0.10 moles
of acetic acid left over.
For hydroxide anions,
we start with 0.10 moles
and we lost 0.10 moles.
Therefore, when the reaction
comes to completion,
there'll be zero moles
of hydroxide anions.
And for the acetate anion,
we started off with
zero and we gained 0.10.
Therefore, we will have 0.10
moles of the acetate anion.
So in this case, we started
with more of our weak acid
than we did of our strong base.
And therefore, we ended up
with acid being in excess.
The next step is to
calculate the concentration
of acetic acid in solution.
So we ended up with 0.10
moles of acetic acid.
So we plug that into our
equation for molarity.
And when we mixed our
two solutions together,
the 100 milliliters of our weak acid
with the 100 milliliters
of our strong base,
the total volume of the
solution is 200 milliliters
or 0.200 liters.
Therefore, 0.1 divided by 0.200,
gives the concentration
of acetic of 0.50 molar.
And for the acetate anion,
we also had 0.10 moles.
The total volume is the same,
so it's the same calculation as before.
0.10 moles divided by 0.200 liters,
gives the concentration of
acetate anions of 0.50 molar.
Remember, our goal was to calculate the pH
of the resulting solution.
So to calculate the pH,
we're gonna need the
concentration of acetic acid
and the concentration of acetate anions.
So we know we have some
acetic acid in solution,
and acetic acid reacts with water
to form the hydronium ion, H3O+,
and the acetate anion, CH3COO-.
This reaction is a weak
acid equilibrium problem,
so we have an equilibrium arrow,
and we're gonna set up an ICE table
for initial concentration,
change in concentration,
and equilibrium concentration.
We just calculated the
initial concentration
of acetic acid to be 0.50 molar.
And if we pretend like the
acetic acid hasn't ionized yet,
the initial concentration of
hydronium ions would be zero
and the initial concentration
of acetate anions
from the ionization would be zero.
However, we just calculated
that there is a concentration
of acetate anions
already in solution,
and that concentration was 0.50 molar.
So on the ICE table, I'm
gonna write in here 0.50
for the acetate anion.
Next, we think about some
of the acetic acid ionizing,
and we don't know how much,
so we're gonna call that x.
So under the change,
we're gonna write minus x.
The mole ratio of acetic
acid to hydronium ion
is one-to-one.
So if we write minus x under acetic acid,
we need to write plus x
under the hydronium ion.
And for the acetate anion,
there's also a coefficient of one,
so we're gonna write plus
x under the acetate anion.
Therefore, the equilibrium concentration
of acetic acid is 0.50 minus x.
And for hydronium ion,
it would be zero plus x or just x.
And for the acetate anion,
it would be zero plus 0.50 plus x
or just 0.50 plus x.
Notice that there are two
sources of the acetate anion.
The 0.50 molar
came from the weak acid-strong
base neutralization reaction
that we previously discussed.
The other source of the acetate anion
comes from the ionization of acetic acid,
and that's this x here.
So 0.50 plus x indicates
there are two sources
for this common ion.
Therefore, this is a
common-ion effect problem.
The next step is to
write the Ka expression
for acetic acid.
So we can get that from
the balanced equation.
The Ka value for acetic
acid at 25 degrees Celsius
is equal to the concentration
of hydronium ions
raised to the first power
times the concentration of acetate anions
divided by the
concentration of acetic acid
raised to the first power,
with water being left
out of our equilibrium
constant expression.
Next, we plug in our
equilibrium concentrations
from our ICE table.
For the hydronium ion, it's x.
For the acetate anion, it's 0.50 plus x.
And for acetic acid it's 0.50 minus x.
Here, we have our equilibrium
concentrations plugged in
and also the Ka value for acetic
acid at 25 degrees Celsius.
Next, we need to solve for x.
And to make the math easier,
we can make an approximation.
With a relatively low value
for Ka for acetic acid,
acetic acid doesn't ionize very much.
Therefore, we know that x is
gonna be a very small number.
And if x is a very small
number compared to 0.50,
0.50 plus x is
approximately equal to 0.50.
The same idea applies to 0.50 minus x.
If x is a very small
number compared to 0.50,
0.50 minus x is
approximately equal to 0.50.
And with our approximations,
the 0.50s would cancel out and give us x
is equal to 1.8 times 10
to the negative fifth.
From our ICE table,
we know that x is equal to
the equilibrium concentration
of hydronium ions.
Therefore, at equilibrium,
the concentration of hydronium ions
is equal to 1.8 times 10 to
the negative fifth molar.
And because our goal was to
find the pH of the solution,
pH is equal to the negative
log of the concentration
of hydronium ions.
So when we plug in that concentration,
we get the pH is equal
to negative log of 1.8 times
10 to the negative fifth
which is equal to 4.74.
So if you react a weak
acid with a strong base
and the weak acid is in excess,
the pH of the solution
will be less than seven.
It'll be acidic.